so you were in the middle of moonland
rouge like yes when everything started
shutting down that
that sucks yeah it was uh i mean
obviously it was
difficult for everyone but we were kind
of on this freight train of a show that
had been running for
nine months and it just kind of all just
came to a stop and we had no idea i mean
we thought kind of much like everyone
else that
it'd be two weeks or a month or you know
i think if if somebody had told me
that here we would be and broadway still
wasn't open i'd
i would have a never believed them but
also it just you could have never
processed it
i know i kept thinking people coming
like from a different time and all of a
sudden just being dropped and being like
yeah what's happening yeah yeah yeah
especially cities like new york yeah
it's like a very dystopian kind of
post something it was like look we
didn't want to live the will smith movie
right yeah
here we go yeah yep i'm still here just
waiting for you to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever